bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
journal de l'afrique sur france 24 à la
une de l'actualité africaine ce soir la
situation politique au tchad ce week-end
certains groupes politico militaires ont
claqué la porte des négociations à doha
alors quel avenir pour les pourparlers
de paix on en parlera en plateau avec
mamadou lô jim t by notre correspondant
à djamena
le cameroun confrontés à une pénurie de
carburant les stations service sont à
sec l'envolée des cours du pétrole rend
les importations plus difficile
reportage à yaoundé à suivre et enfin ce
18 juillet la journée internationale
nelson mandela journée qui met en avant
l'engagement associatif et la solidarité
en hommage au premier président noir
sud-africain également symbole de la
lutte contre l'apartheid nous irons au
cap dans ce journal
il y a quatre mois groupe rebelle et
autorités tchadiennes ont donc entamé
des pourparlers de paix mais ce week end
à doha où il disait près de la moitié
des groupes politico militaires présents
ont décidé de quitter la table des
négociations va en parler avec vous
mamadou jim t by notre correspondant à
djamena de passage à paris bonjour
nomade où ces groupes rebelles il accuse
le gouvernement tchadien d'intimidation
oui entre autres il parle de corruption
d'art seulement de menace et de
tentatives de déstabilisation
ccc
ccc personnes soit un groupe parmi le
groupe doit faut savoir qu'à doha et à
50 groupes rebelles qui sont là pour les
pourparlers pour la paix au tchad ils
avancent depuis à tâtons disons que il
ya des avancées et des reculs hâte mais
la situation semble s'accélérer ces
derniers temps et c'est ce groupe qui
est qui qui fait partie comme je le
disais tout à l'heure à trouver que la
partie gouvernementale ne jouaient pas
le jeu et qu'il leur cachet beaucoup de
choses du côté du gouvernement
pour eux tout semble aller dans le bon
sens ils ne comprennent pas ce serait
vraiment et avancent le fait qu'en fait
c'est pas tous les politiques ou
militaires qui ont décidé de suspendre
leur participation à ces pourparlers par
la même occasion chercher que c'est une
suspension mais ce n'est pas un retrait
parce que ce même groupe qui a annoncé
la suspension est en train de travail
sur le document
d'accord qui a été soumis par le
médiateur qatari et le gouvernement
justement il a annoncé dans ce contexte
la tenue fin août du dialogue national
de paie toutes ces initiatives elles ont
pour but finalement de mettre fin à des
décennies d'instabilité dans le pays
tout à fait et pour juste plus de
classement sachez que la lance de
suspension décidée ce groupe peuple qui
comme iter est arrivé à vingt quatre
heures après qu'ils aient la manche due
à la date du prochain dialogue qui est
fixée au 20 août ce dialogue est un
élément crucial dans le processus de
conditions à quoi encore sachez que
c'est cet événement qui va vraiment
dessiner le contour du cat de demain
donc c'est un élément important
il se veut inclusif et même souverain
dans son caractère inclusif on ne peut
pas à occulter la partie politico
militaire parce que vous savez que on a
souvent des problèmes d'ordre militaire
les rébellions et autres dont il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à amener sur la
table de discussion les
politico-militaires donc on espère que
dans les jours à venir si je m'en tiens
à ce que j'ai comme échange avec les
membres des différentes délégations
aussi bien des politiques monétaires qui
ont réfusé de qui ont suspendu leur
participation ou ceux qui disent que non
nous on continue en discussion et la
partie gouvernementale
tout le monde espère avoir rapidement
disons d'ici le 20
juillet un an le 20 août 20 août au lam
accord merci beaucoup mamadou jeans t by
merci pour cet éclairage tôt on va
partir a à présent au cameroun voisin le
cameroun qui comme d'autres pays du
continent fait face depuis plusieurs
jours à une pénurie de carburant
l'envolée des cours du brent rend plus
difficile l'importation des produits
pétroliers résultat est bien les files
d'attentes s'allongent devant les
stations essence le reportage à yaoundé
de nos correspondants mars l amoco tony
menga et michel blondeau
de longues files d'attentes devant les
stations-service de yaoundé c'est le
spectacle quotidien auquel participent
les automobilistes qui a mené depuis
quelques jours des plus 10h30
un gasol qui se fait rare à cause d'une
baisse des importations de carburant
raffiné qui a vu remporter subventionnés
qui coûte de plus en plus cher aux
caisses de l'état d'où cette pénurie qui
paralyse l'activité des chauffeurs de
taxi comme ismaël à sa fait 2 + 2 à 8
ans que je suis là watan le gabon reste
le point noir de six mois roger des
clients à porter je sais pas comment je
le fais sur le jeu d'attentes quelques
mètres plus loin c'est d'autres stations
de service a décidé de rationner le
précieux liquide seulement 7 litres
autorisés d'avril
plus moyen de faire le plein la tête je
veux faire ça dit à plus de 50 litres on
te dit c'est impossible parce que si on
était cette fois seuls les 50 litres à
les autres n'ont pas fait
même plus dans le cadre des actions aux
pays bas face à la pénurie le
gouvernement s'est voulu rassurant en
annonçant de nouvelles importations de
carburant mais il reconnaît que la
facture devient intenable pour les
finances publiques 80 milliards de
francs cfa par mois soit environ 122
millions d'euros l'addition est
importante pour un pays qui est pourtant
producteur de pétrole une situation
dénoncée par cet expert en perd de
l'argent à sa chute en du pétrole
étranger donc à monde se doit se doter
d'une raffinerie brun capable de
raffiner son pétrole sont fût-elle
lourds ou pouvoir pour nos matchs locaux
l'état comme en europe a besoin de
subventionner le carburant dans ce cas
si ce pétrole raffiné
pour l'instant les prix à la pompe reste
stable mais la presse le cal annonce de
prochaines augmentations
d'autant plus que le fonds monétaire
international réclame au gouvernement
camerounais la fin des subventions qui
plombe les caisses de l'état de quoi
faire flamber les coûts du carburant
dans une économie déjà impacté par une
inflation galopante
les européens eux craignent des pénuries
de gaz cet hiver à cause bien sûr de la
guerre en ukraine en réaction aux
sanctions moscou en effet déjà commencé
à fermer le robinet alors pour
diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement rome se tourner vers
l'algérie mario draghi le premier
ministre italien était à alger ce lundi
plusieurs accords vous allez le voir ont
été signés charlie singbo
avec sa deuxième visite en trois mois
mario draghi est presque un habitué du
palais présidentiel algérien
cette fois le chef du gouvernement
italien copréside le quatrième sommet
algéro-italien avec le président
abdelmadjid tebboune il signe surtout
des accords commerciaux sa grande
urgence remplacer le gaz russe dont
l'italie dépend à 45% l'algérie
acceptent d'augmenter ses exportations
une cause des musées l'algérie est
devenue le premier exportateur de gaz
vers l'italie
c'est l'union européenne qui a décidé de
réduire sa consommation de gaz russe
pour protester contre l'invasion de
l'ukraine faire pression sur vladimir
poutine pour les pays européens surtout
ceux qui dépendent largement de moscou
c'est une course contre la montre pour
trouver des alternatives
mario draghi et ses ministres enchaîne
les visites du congo-brazzaville en
angola et en libye ou encore dans les
émirats arabes unis bon point pour
l'italie il existe des gazoducs la
religion à l'algérie et à la libye et
son géant de l'énergie eni est le
premier producteur étranger en afrique
depuis le début de l'année l'algérie a
déjà augmenté de 113 % les volumes
fournis à l'italie il s'agit d'éviter
une pénurie un blocage des industries
italienne et de freiner la hausse des
prix
en république démocratique du congo ce
lundi marquait dans le pays le lancement
de l'examen d'état l'équivalent du
baccalauréat en france mais cette année
avec la reprise des affrontements entre
l'armée le groupe rebelle m23 des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants ont dû
fuir et se sont retrouvés privés de
cours alors pour qu'il puisse malgré
tout passer leurs examens l'unicef et
plusieurs ong se sont mobilisés elles
ont aidé 324 de ses enfants qui
s'étaient réfugiés en ouganda a regagné
rutshuru au nord-kivu
clément boudreau et justin kalumba les
ont rencontrés
les meilleurs élèves sont allés à new
gold
mais même là toute la population on
était allé là bas quand on était là ne
faisait pas des études et donc est sûre
nous avons réuni ici juste pour fait les
aider mais on n'a pas beaucoup étudié là
où je t'ai réfugiés j'ai fait là la
révision et j'ai essayé de contacter les
amis pour un plus s'expliquer ensemble
c'est vraiment important qu'ils passent
les épreuves parce que ce sont des
enfants congolais on ne peut pas l'air
privés de leurs droits ils ont les
doigts de passer à l'examen d'état comme
cela se passe sur tout le territoire
national
je vous le disais dans les titres ce 18
juillet la journée internationale de
nelson mandela date de la naissance du
prix nobel 1993 institué en afrique du
sud puis dans le monde entier dès 2009
cette journée met en avant l'engagement
associatif et la solidarité au cas pour
retrouve caroline dumay notre
correspondante
ici en afrique du sud la journée nelson
mandela c'est la journée du volontariat
nelson mandela a consacré 67 années de
sa vie à aider ses concitoyens et bien
les sud africains consacrent au moins 67
minutes de leur journée à aider
également leurs voisins et cette année
au l'un des thèmes très à la mode
c'était 2 nourrir la population pourquoi
et bien parce qu'on considère qu'au
moins 20 % des sud-africains sont en
état d'insécurité alimentaire et sur le
continent africain 40 millions de
personnes seraient menacées de famine
donc c'est un thème qui était très
populaire cette année ici au cap on a
construit avec des boîtes de conserve
cet énorme mosaïque représentant le
visage de nelson mandela et le drapeau
sud africain pour le responsable de
l'omg qui a coordonné les efforts
c'était un immense succès
ça a été incroyable
on a eu plus de mille personnes venues
faire leurs 67 minutes il y a des gens
qui me demandent vous allez continuer
longtemps comme ça à distribuer de la
nourriture et je leur réponds qu'est ce
qui est mieux sur le long terme ignorer
la réalité ou faire ce qu'on peut pour
aider à améliorer notre pays pour moi
c'est crucial on envoie 40 tonnes de
nourriture par semaine ça représente 250
mille repas par semaine et dans la
province de johannesbourg ont fait 38 de
repas près de cinq tonnes de nourriture
par semaine voilà pour moi c'est
important il ya des gens qui n'ont rien
à manger
les bigoudens impute win it be défaut
même et puis on a fait aussi plus de
20000 sandwich qu'on distribuera dans
les écoles maternelles de la province
comme l'expliqué le président cyril
ramaphosa dans un message ce matin il
revient souvent à la société civile de
rappeler les idéaux de nelson mandela
allez pour finir on va partir au
festival d'avignon dans le sud de la
france dans le cadre de savard savent
allemande organisée par radio france
internationale on a pu entendre hier
dimanche un texte de l'écrivain
sénégalais mohamed bogard sarr prix
goncourt 2021 c'est l'artiste burkinabè
aristide tard honda qui a signé cette
adaptation et mise en voie de terre
sainte le livre publié en 2015 qui
raconte l'histoire d'une ville contrôlée
par la terreur des islamistes on va
écouter tout de suite mohamed gars art
qui tente
de réfléchir à la résistance à ce qu'est
la résistance à ce que la résistance
pose comme question à la nécessité de la
résistance mais c'est une réflexion qui
est mise au service d'une action de la
vie concrète sous considère que dans mes
romans une grande part est inspiré du
théâtre disons que c'est un genre que je
respecte tellement que je porte
tellement haut que je ne m'en fais pas
directement
mais il ya toujours une attention au
théâtre notamment à la question de la
voix et où la question du libre dans mes
dormi dedans mais peut-être qu'un jour
j'ai pilé plus directement dans le lent
mais pour l'heure ce n'est pas au
programme cette affaire on voit je
préfère écouter je peux faire on va
discuter avec les gens du théâtre voilà
des propos recueillis par janvier ce bug
ça va ça va le monde qui fête ses 10 ans
cette année se poursuit au festival
d'avignon jusqu'à mercredi voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal de l'afrique rester
avec nous sur france 24 l'information
continue
[Musique]